bonjour estelle à gages exquis merci
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france est-ce que vous vous sentez
stigmatisé par tous ces débats autour de
la vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants oui complètement effectivement
c'est la deuxième fois depuis le début
de la pandémie que les stigmatiser comme
des vecteurs de du virus à savoir quand
même qui a eu environ 59 milles soignons
qui ont été infectées depuis le début de
cette pandémie
donc on est vraiment stigmatiser a comme
comme des vecteurs et comme des
malveillants envers le reste de la
population alors à tort évidemment 1 59
mille personnes contaminées par le virus
justement alors j'allais vous dire juste
or justement est-ce qu'il faut pas se
faire vacciner selon vous alors alors si
justement on est on est favorable à la
vaccination en fait ce qu'il faut
recontextualiser c'est que depuis le
début de la gestion de la crise il ya un
gros problème de communication qui émane
du coup leur nom c'est à dire qu'on a eu
des informations des désinformations
depuis le début concernant les masques
concernant les moyens de protection dans
leur globalité est aussi une commande
pour la population comme quoi ils
n'étaient pas capables en fait de
respecter certaines n'est pas capable de
mettre des masques quand même
correctement et c'est tout ça pour en
fait dissimuler une pénurie de moyens et
donc en fait on se rend compte que tout
ce qui a été mis en place par le
gouvernement notamment le tracé isolé
qui n'a jamais été
réalisée de manière efficace il a vidé
des caisses primaires d'assurance
maladie ou des agences régionales de
santé
en fait on se rend compte que il ya un
réel problème d'information via le
gouvernement est donc en fait la
population française dont fait partie
les soignants peuvent avoir des doutes à
être méfiants même concernant le vaccin
il ya eu tellement en fait de
l'information sur les vaccins mais qui
n'étaient pas forcément les bonnes par
rapport aux phases d'essais et cetera
avec les premières vagues de soignants
également qu'ils se sont fait vacciner
avec l'astra zeneca où ça a été une
hécatombe sur les 48 que les 72 heures
qui ont suivi la vaccination
effectivement c'est un peu exagéré il ya
eu des cas effectivement de
complications et quatre attaquants ce
qui est exagéré
alors quand je dis hécatombe c'est à
dire quand même des professionnels qui
le lendemain de leur de leur vaccination
n'ont pas pu aller travailler
ça veut dire quand même que déjà à
l'hôpital lorsqu'on a des soucis
d'effectif qui sont remontés déjà depuis
plus d'un an et demi quand vous avez
tout un service qui qui se retrouve en
fait sans infirmer ou sans aides
soignants ça pose quand même
sérieusement problème donc pour vous
c'est plus un problème de demande de
confiance
si la vaccination devient obligatoire
que va-t-il se passer on l'a vu en
italie il y a eu des renvois pour des
personnels soignants qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés est ce que vous craignez ce
scénario oui mais on craint c'est
exactement ce que l'on dénonce en fait
avec le collectif intérieur gens c'est
le collectif inter hôpitaux c'est à dire
que là nous sommes déjà en pénurie de
en manque d'effectif sur le système de
santé publique
donc en fait si on oblige les soignants
certains soignants à se vacciner
ça va être pris comme une sanction pour
certains et donc en fait on risque
d'avoir des départs massifs ou alors de
faim de l'hôpital donc ce qui fait que
ceux qui vont êtres qui sont déjà
vaccinés ou qui sont encore présents à
l'hôpital risque de rencontrer encore
plus de problèmes pour pouvoir assurer
en fait les soins correctement
je pense sincèrement que le l'a fait la
vaccination est très importante
le message qui doit être passée c'est
qu'à vaccination est importante et que
elle a des effets favorables en fait sur
les les cas graves
on peut le voir au niveau des
hospitalisations ou en fait ça très
favorable favorablement baissé mais je
pense que l'information la communication
en fait du gouvernement en menaçant
ainsi n'est pas favorable à ce que ça se
passe correctement dans la globalité de
la population de soignante comme au
niveau de la population en général
donc il faut il faut passer un message
favorable tout en expliquant
correctement à quoi sert la vaccination
quel type de vaccin et
pour quelle raison en fait il est
important de se faire vacciner
inciter fortement mais pas contraindre
ses escaliers laurent berger on a
entendu vous ne faites pas partie des
organisations qui seront reçus par
olivier ferrand
cet après midi on verra ce qu'il en est
ce qu'il en ressort merci beaucoup et ce
tel gadget ski d'avoir répondu ce matin
en direct à nos questions sur rt france